a diferencia de job hay de manuel la
mamá con decidió llamar a vladimir putin
aunque primero lo consultó con su
homólogo ucraniano volodymyr a ese
lenski macrón aprovechó la oportunidad
para exigirle el cese inmediato de las
operaciones militares rusas en
territorio ucraniano y le recordó a
vladimir putin las masivas sanciones a
las que se expone su país según el
comunicado del kremlin que dio a conocer
la conversación entre los dos
presidentes fue una conversación franca
una conversación seria que le permitió
también a vladimir putin explicar las
razones detalladamente de por qué
decidió lanzar esta ofensiva militar en
la madrugada de este jueves sin embargo
esta llamada también deja entender que
emanuel manjón considera todavía hay la
posibilidad de que se pueda resolver
este conflicto por la vía de la
diplomacia y además pues es también la
primera conversación que de la que al
menos se sepa que haya tenido vladimir
putin hoy con un mandatario occidental
justamente el día en que lanzó estas
operaciones militares contra ucrania